yeah because I know I did notice that
like the week before we had like a cold
front or something and yeah dropped like
10 degrees Yeah Yeah like we uh we had a
trip planned to Sapporo when Sydney's
family was in the country and we had to
cancel that yeah
um which you know it turned out to be a
blessing in disguise because they really
we went ended up going to yamanashi
um
like no yeah much much warmer uh no snow
there still very very cold but just no
snow or anything like that yeah um ended
up having a fantastic time as well yeah
a little thing I noticed uh taking
Sydney's family around the countryside
um for some reason okay for some reason
obviously yamanashi I don't think it's a
lot of like foreign tourists compared to
Tokyo Osaka maybe yeah maybe Mount Fuji
but we weren't we weren't near anywhere
like too close to Mount Fuji
um so we went we showed them to a lot of
our you know favorite wineries where me
and Sydney would go
um since you know that's kind of the
area we know test and as soon as a lot
of these local Japanese people saw that
there were foreign tourists of course
they'd be scared at first but as soon as
they could tell me in city started
speaking Japanese like for some reason
the combination of foreign tourists and
a few of them that could speak Japanese
um they they went from Super scared to
inviting us to see like some of the most
intimate parts of their like
establishments and houses I don't know
what this switch was but I remember we
went to one with this one Winery and uh
we were trying trying a bunch of wines
and everything like that and at first
they were like oh sorry uh we don't know
if you can try all the wines you want
and something like that
um and then uh we were waiting you know
we were we were outside just trying the
wine and the owner uh comes up to uh
comes up to me and Sydney
um and you know starts asking us oh why
why are you guys here and I was like oh
yeah we live in Japan we're just showing
our parents around uh since this is the
first time to Japan and he as soon as as
soon as he saw that as soon as he heard
that and as soon as he started hearing
that you know we live in Japan he was
like I gotta show you something and I
was like what what is going on what are
you buying what are you selling and then
he takes it he takes us around he takes
us around behind the winery to this like
little back little shed and he's just
like oh oh this is it yeah so so none of
this uh none of this is for sale this is
all my hobby and he and he opens the
door and it's a full-on like home brew
Distillery
he's got this little shed and he's like
I'm trying to make gin this is a wine by
the way uh so he's mad scientists so
literally he was like uh I've cracked
the formula I'm going to make it it's
like a Crackdown this is my personal
collection of men yeah he was like he
just literally just opened up this
little [__] he's like so that Winery is
my business this this is like my hobby
and I wanted to show you guys my little
closet isn't just a business it's your
passion
and he just he takes out this [__]
full-on jaw it's it is literally like a
jar no packaging whatever it is just a
jar Scoops out a little bit of gin
would you like to try some it's a new
it's a new concoction I've been working
on was it good actually it was pretty it
was pretty damn decent actually
[Music]
back shed gin made in Japan
it's probably the safest country in the
world to go into someone's shed and
drink their alcohol yeah still I don't
know I mean I would get it if it was
like you know a gin Distillery right but
like I mean I mean like it's like to
give credit to the this is what I say
yeah I'm just Clowning on the whole shed
part but yeah I mean it was a shed but
that's just because you know
um he does he has had he has built a
pretty big Winery for himself right and
it's one of the most famous wineries in
that area I think he just wanted to do
something as like a personal project no
why not um and just start making gin and
I was just like why are you in it's beta
why are you inviting us into your house
it's so weird that they they literally
go from like I just encountered an alien
to being like Oh yes you are family for
a generation yeah yeah people are really
chill especially in the countryside we
um we also found like a brewery in the
middle of like
middle of the yamanashi as well that's
just run by an um American dude it's
super super [__] random shout out to
abina brewery I think that's the name um
they just have like a craft beer Place
yeah right yeah oh is that the crappie
that uh Sydney's dad gave yeah yeah yeah
that's right that's right yeah
yeah that was that was in this Brewery
we found out you had to drive up a
mountain up a really really steep
Mountain same kind of mountain roads and
he is just this sounds like he's living
his best life yeah there's just this
random dude that was Japan that just had
a bunch of loud he built his house
um on this land kind of like raised a
family there uh and uh one day like his
mates were gassing him up that there
were no good craft beer places in Japan
and they were like kind of gassing him
up to be like you could do it you could
do it so he just looked and [__] it I'll
do it myself and you just literally went
[__] it I'll do it myself build his own
brew house right right on this mountain
bruises on a chair and I was talking to
him and he [__] incredible story
where he was just like yeah I just I
just built uh built this brew house all
by myself uh designed it myself and uh
everything what an absolute shot great
[__] beers hell yeah yeah so you can
you can find the most random things
sometimes just in the middle of the
countryside yeah talking about random
like finding like random artifacts these
exist I feel like the most in Japan if
anything oh yeah where you just you go
to like the most remote places and
there'll just be this really weird
random site there yeah you know I mean
you know we experienced that on the the
road trip special right like that
[__] Maui uh sorry the uh the Easter
Island heads in the middle of that like
that was literally in like it was kind
of hard to show in the video but that
was truly in the middle of fall it was
out there there was nothing else around
us it was just there yeah and there's so
many like maybe not to that scale but
yeah as God was saying like there's so
many like either tiny restaurants or
like bars or like where I'm like how the
[__] are you making any money out here
yeah it's odd like you maybe encounter
like one person every two weeks yeah
it's like you run a business out here
like okay yeah I'm sure low cost of
living kind of offsets that a little bit
but I'm like that's this uh still a big
pleasure running right yeah how cheap it
is to run businesses out here yeah it
must be for my word of mouth or
something yeah because otherwise some of
these places is just be like you would
never be able to find it otherwise yeah
glad to say though that
um despite not not despite but
um
or after the first day Sydney's parents
very very much enjoyed Japan and uh they
after the weirdness of the after the
weirdness of the first day the girls
buying everything I kind of like I kind
of think it was a trial by fire because
we had a pretty normal trip afterwards
but after the trial by fire they just
enjoyed every aspect of Japanese culture
that's good kind of a simulated I don't
know if assimilated was is the right
word but kind of got used to it very
very quickly so hopefully your parents
have a similar experience yeah they're
coming on April so it'd be interesting
to see do you have anywhere you're going
to take them like you've already feed it
out or no I haven't I don't know where
to take them what are they I don't want
to go Kyoto but I know they want to go
kyotube maybe I can just send them off
[Laughter]
[Applause]
April it's gonna be so like
have a few days where you take them to
the tourist spots because that's what we
did with his family but you're like you
uh contrast that with just somewhere
outside in the country maybe yeah
or something like that yeah I mean
April's a good time to drive around
Japan yeah the roads are nice it's
really easy weather's perfect so I'm
definitely gonna drive them around
somewhere I haven't decided where
um if you want something close by maybe
like hakone like around there would be
nice yeah I mean I mean you could drive
to you could drive to Kyoto or that kind
of area it's kind of fun drive yeah it's
long yeah when I went to Onsen with my
father and uncle in law now did they
like it they've they absolutely loved
they didn't mind getting naked I had to
do a little bit of convincing honestly
hardest part
it's always the bit before okay so
here's here's the thing when we're in
Tokyo
um and we had to cancel a supper or a
trip yeah they were like just book us a
normal hotel and so they left the
booking to me they wanted just a normal
Hotel I tried to sell them the idea of
the Onsen beforehand and they were just
a little bit of a white lie I was like
there's only a one place that's open
right now
turned out to be a nonsense there were
actually other hotels in the area that
were more traditional without nonsense
but it was all like kind of the same
price I was like I'm gonna go for the
Onsen and uh see where it takes us so I
booked the Onsen and we were there they
really really loved the more traditional
Japanese place I think you know I think
if they if they hadn't experienced that
they wouldn't have known what they were
missing kind of and so when I saw them
really enjoying like the more
traditional Vibes and everything I'm
like I think I can get them so I
remember going to this Brewery with them
and we I gotta got a bit toasted and on
the journey back I'm like
but you guys feel like a nice warm bath
right now I'm just saying
how do you hear me I I'm just saying
hear me out I'm gonna go right now it's
gonna be one of the most relaxing balls
I've taken of my lives you guys can join
me no pressure at all yeah now exactly
and you know what after uh after a long
walk and a few good beers that sounds
like a really really nice idea so just
all it needed was a little bit of a
little bit of convincing and then why do
you do like a tickle in them
that's how it is
stick with the balls just a little bit
but uh yeah no awkwardness at all no
yeah even though it was like you know
technically like family members now no
awkwardness at all everyone enjoyed the
Onsen
um and
you know it really does change the
moment you step foot in the water yeah
honestly oh this was worse have you had
this conversation with people like can I
wear can I wear like swim shorts yeah
you cannot wear swim shorts
no you you can't wear swim shorts you're
not allowed do you always lose shorts in
your bath that's like more offensive
don't wear just don't do it like you
can't go in with swim shorts I'm like
why I'm like I I don't know how to
explain it to you it's the culture I
don't know just get your [__] out and
shut up just put your balls on the back
trust me it'll make sense when you're in
all right like don't don't be coming in
with swimsuit yeah an old Japanese lady
will come in and kill you yeah
I'm like why like because it's because
the view it is like you've got to be
clean you kind of foreign objects going
it's like dirty yeah no it's not dirty
and you probably washed them but it's
not how it works like you can't you're
not allowed okay yeah I don't I don't
come into your house making up rules
about who can go and walk back yeah
follow their rules like I get it you're
not comfortable but what do you mean I'm
not allowed to pee in the sink I just
really
my friend's shower even though I do it
in mine yeah I don't know it definitely
I don't know if it is like a mental
thing but it definitely feels a lot
cleaner being naked because I remember
when I when I went back to England I
went to your bath and we went to like
one of the Spas there uh and they have
like they have like very kind of like
similar Spas where it's kind of not just
a pool but like I call it a hot tub yeah
because you're still in there with
shorts and there's just something about
being there
in shorts and seeing other people in
shorts that it just maybe it's a mental
thing but it definitely doesn't feel as
refreshing or as clean yeah you know
it's especially when everyone has to
bathe before they can enter as well yeah
I think that's that's also important
right yeah I'm gonna try and get my
parents to go one we'll see what they
say yeah I'm doubtful I feel like my I
explained the idea of my mum she seemed
really against it she seemed like no I
can't do that yeah no no my dad I think
my dad's probably he I think he wanted
to seemed chill but I feel like he won't
like it either
I don't know my brothers are down though
my brother's really chill they're like
sure yeah if I tell them it's the
culture they'll be like I guess yeah
there's like there is nothing you can do
about it it is the culture just stuff
that like I have to eat this I have to
eat it
you will you'll literally get stabbed by
the sushi chef if you don't finish this
just just put them in a situation where
not Onsen just feels really enticing
because as soon as you get them in the
mindset to be like just gas them up a
little bit
yeah I'll just be like the beer
afterwards is going to be the most
refreshing beer of your life which it is
I've also I gotta I gotta think of new
names for fish to lie to them so they
don't know what the actual fish is
because if I tell them what it is they
want to eat it I think like what like
the rose I went to a sushi restaurant
yesterday and they served eel and it was
really really good it didn't it takes so
meaty yeah and I know that if you tell
someone it's ill they'll be like no yeah
yeah but it looks like breakfast
honestly I don't know how he did this
but this eel like a piece of mackerel
yeah on top and I was like huh just tell
them it's mackerel everything's mackerel
just be like we don't have an English
name we just called unagi let's just see
this yeah it's like but what does that
translate
some of them I know they're probably not
gonna like I'll be surprised they like
sea urchin because I don't like sea
urchin that [__] well yeah yeah I mean
like with things like with things like
sea urchin and even like salmon Roe for
a lot of people it's like it's a lot for
people well we'll see we'll see I'll see
they probably want to go Kyoto there and
I'm again I'm dreading that I don't I
really don't wanna I'm thinking I might
try and be like you've been in Japan a
week now you're ready
I just I Kyoto is a really cool place
but I've only been with them when
there's no tourists and even then it
felt like a lot I don't know why kid is
cool but I'm I just don't think it's
like my kind of place almost like it's
way more my speed yeah I like the party
Vibes
feels like a theme park in a lot of ways
yeah where it's like it's like it
doesn't feel like it's an authentic
Japanese experience even though it's the
most authentic thing it feels super
stiff super I mean it is old school but
but like it has that Vibe and like me
personally I like the just the the laid
backness of other areas of Japan a lot
more yeah oh no I totally get that feel
because actually when you guys came to
Thailand like and I was thinking about
where I could take you guys I really
wanted to take it there's a lot of like
temples in Bangkok right but there's
just something about the vibe where you
take you take you know people were
visiting to a temple and you know the
architecture [__] we saw some of them
yeah beautiful beautiful all gold and
everything but it's just so many
tourists so many people just taking
pictures it's just you kind of like lose
a little bit of a sense of what made
this what makes this place so amazing in
the first place in my opinion and I get
that same kind of feeling with Kyoto as
well where it was super cool to see when
the streets were empty and there was
like no one there obviously bad for the
city bad for business there
um but honestly I I've like I I've
enjoyed just going to some other temples
in Japan where it's a bit more isolated
oh yeah and Kyoto prices are nuts yeah
the uh ryokans and hotels and Kyoto are
so expensive oh yeah yeah you liked it
that's so far that whole area though
like NADA and Osaka as well is like they
all Uprising for that I've never been to
Nara and I I don't care about feeding
these deer why do people care so much
about this to be fair not uh I think out
of all the prefixes I've been to Nada
was probably the most underwhelming
because like you could feed elsewhere
okay look like you know as someone who
loves animals feeding the deer it's
pretty hype it's pretty fun especially
if you go with a bunch of people who are
like you know not that good with animals
and seeing them [__] their pants is
really fun but other than that and the
giant uh the massive uh bronze Buddha
statue that they have there there isn't
really a whole lot to do in Nara if I'm
being honest like it's it's kind of
underwhelming that like there's maybe a
couple of like dishes that you can only
get in Nara but it's not anything like
yeah mind-blowing if you ask me like
most if you want the good food you just
go to Osaka and if you want the culture
you go to Kyoto it's like nara's kind of
in the middle of that and it's not
really yeah I mean I I think we've just
been living here long enough where I
just enjoy just driving around small
areas yeah just seeing all the weird
stuff they have and just kind of
checking that out it's been way more fun
I agree it's a touristy place that's
only because we've lived here and
obviously if you come here the first
time you should go and do the touristy
stuff because that is cool it is cool if
you're going for the first time go to
Kyoto go to narrago yeah they're awesome
but yeah after a while you just feel
like I think I'm good yeah just yeah
just driving around is my favorite part
as well yeah yeah you'll drive more God
I'm looking for more opportunities I'm
glad I'm glad I got one you know with
this but you know yeah next time as well
next time next time can't relate